welcome back everybody lawyers are
working their way through the jury
selection process in the case of Aaron
Dean this is the white Fort Worth police
officer who shot and killed a black
woman through a window of her very own
home Atiana Jefferson died in October of
2019. according to witness testimony
Jefferson was babysitting her nephew
when they heard a sound and thought that
there was a Prowler now Jefferson
licensed to carry a gun pointed it
toward a window meanwhile Dean and other
officers had responded to a call from a
neighbor about a door to the home being
open and that is when Dean shot
Jefferson through the window on body cam
video Dean has heard telling Jefferson
to put up her hands but never identified
himself as a police officer when Dean
was charged with her killing he resigned
from the Fort Worth Police Department
he's entered a not guilty plea but it's
not clear what his defense is actually
going to be the defense hopes to have a
jury seated by Friday Brian you've been
following this case pretty closely you
know this happened in a time when we had
unfortunately similar situations where
police officers shot people in their
homes as far as we know weren't
committing any crimes what are your
thoughts on what we're seeing here yeah
Jesse you're right I've been following
Tatiana Jefferson since news first broke
of her death over three years ago now
since then we've been asking how does a
non-emergency call for a front door open
lead to the death of a woman in her
mother's home while watching her nephew
Aaron Dean did everything wrong here he
approached a home in a non-emergency
call as if it was a break-in there was
no reason for him to walk past that
front door without announcing that
police were there he then walks to the
back of the house as you can kind of see
in this video when he figures uh and
then when he gets to a figure in the
back window it's literally a second
between him saying put your hands up and
shooting at Tatiana Jefferson at the
same time the shooting was compared to
the killing of both and Jean a black man
killed in his own home when a former
officer Amber Geiger accidentally walked
into his apartment and the comparison
seems appropriate here now they did find
a gun Dean says that he shot when he
perceived some sort of a threat but he
didn't scream out gun like an officer
typically does in a search in this type
of situation if there is a defense I
would think it'd be self-defense and no
I don't think just because it's
self-defense Dean has to testify but in
a case like this where it objectively
looks like he messed up I think he may
have to take the stand and explain what
he was doing but it's going to be a long
road for him to try to convince a jury
that this was self-defense in any way
shape or form now jury selection is
still underway as they're trying to seek
14 jurors this is a difficult task for
the defense as both sides are focused on
where potential jurors consume their
news and seeking opinions on if they
think police treat people of color
differently Terry this case has been
delayed multiple times why was that the
case and do you think that's going to
affect an upcoming trial well the delays
were different delays the first delay
was coveted and that was all the cases
that we were seeing there was about a
year delay for that but then after that
defense counsel moved to recuse the
judge they moved to remove the trial out
to another venue and they basically just
used every tactic they possibly could to
delay it was set for June and then after
that they said the judge wasn't being
fair and then they said it for just this
past week so I definitely think that
justice has been delayed evidence grows
cold the victims and their family aren't
going to be able to get you know some
sort of closure until this trial is over
so many delays but far more than most
cases and we need to see this trial come
to you know an end here Brian I'll give
you 10 seconds how important is jury
selection for both sides it's everything
how do you feel about guns police people
in their own homes not committing crimes
that could be the big decider in this
trial all right well a woman who
survived the mass shooting at a Virginia
Walmart says that she told the
higher-ups at Walmart that Andre Bing
was acting strangely the woman has now
filed a 50 million dollar lawsuit
against Walmart for not taking steps to
either fire Bing or get him help in the
suit the plaintiff says that the shooter
mocked her for being poor and being
short and made inappropriate comments
about her age and whether she would have
any children the plaintiff says that she
has PTSD from seeing her co-workers get
shot Bing killed six people last week as
his overnight supervisor shift was
getting started and he then turned the
gun on himself
while the legal team for a now disgraced
South Carolina attorney facing double
murder charges has filed several motions
that they hope are going to help their
client Alec Murdock is accused of
killing his wife Maggie and Son Paul at
one of their homes the two were found
shot to death near the family's dog
kennel in 2021. the latest motion
focuses on blood spatter a company hired
by the South Carolina law enforcement
division originally said stains a
Murdoch shirt were likely transfer
stains but when the report was submitted
the company changed its opinion to say
that there were more than 100 high
velocity blood spatter stains on Murdoch
sure the defense is questioning whether
the company was pressured to change the
report and wants the agency to turn over
all Communications about blood spatter
we have new information about how
investigators are connecting a Delphi
Indiana man to the killing of two
teenage girls their bodies found near a
popular hiking trail five years ago
investigators believe Richard Allen
killed Libby German and Abby William in
2017. according to a newly released
probable cause affidavit police found an
unspent bullet between the bodies of the
two girls that bullet has been connected
back to a pistol owned by Richard Allen
Allen told police he never loaned his
gun to anyone and didn't know how an
unspent round could have ended up could
have ended up at the crime scene Allen's
legal team has filed a request for a
change of venue saying that the media
coverage of the small town slangs will
have tainted the local jury pool Andrew
Baldwin an attorney for Allen called the
affidavit flimsy but we reached out to
another criminal defense attorney to get
his take on the new documents here's
what Bob Mata attorney and host of The
True Crime podcast defense Diaries had
to say
I think that there's a sense of urgency
when you see a probable cause affidavit
like this as defense counsel
you seriously become concerned that your
client truly is innocent and they're now
sitting in jail which will be at that
point
four months
you know without any kind of real
evidence so if I'm I'm defense counsel
I'm going in I'm saying you need to
start giving me some Discovery show me
something you know because they're going
to see it anyway I think if they come
back with no no DNA match in terms of
Richard Allen I think he might get Bond
based on this I really do
all right I want to bring in co-hosts
former trial Attorney Terry Austin in
New York City homicide public defender
Brian buckmeier to talk about this case
Terry I'll start with you affidavit
contains details about these Witnesses
who may have seen Alan but do you think
that descriptions are going to be
detailed enough to prove this case
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt because that's
what we're talking about well not based
on that affidavit maybe they have other
information they did talk about the fact
that they had information from forensics
and they have you know Witnesses who say
they saw it but this affidavit is flimsy
I agree it says that these Witnesses saw
him but the descriptions are different
the only thing that was etched and stone
is the drop-off time and the time that
that video was taken that's the only
definitive piece of information in there
different heights different colored
clothing and so I think based on that
just identity in this case is all about
identity I think based on that there
will be at this point I have Reasonable
Doubt hmm well Brian based on these
strengths or maybe the weaknesses of the
affidavit what's going to come next in
the case yeah Mata had the nail on the
head if I'm the defense attorney in this
case I'm rushing to the judge and saying
judge look at this affidavit it's weak
we need something more if we're going to
keep this person Richard Allen Behind
Bars there's going to be an urgency to
try to get him out because many people
ask me Brian is it hard to represent
people who are guilty I say no it's
innocent guilty people go to jail but
when you truly think that you have a
client who's potentially innocent you
will move mountains to ensure that they
get out of jail so they're not being
held during the tendency of the case and
make sure they get out from any
potential guilty verdicts I expect a
bond him to happen soon and for him to
potentially get some amount of bail till
you can get out yeah we're kind of in
the beginning stages of this but we're
going to continue to follow it because
it's interesting to say the least after
five years we're sort of getting answers
we do have an update for you though in
the case of Vanessa Guillen this is the
soldier stationed at Fort Hood in Texas
when she was killed Cecily Aguilar
pleaded guilty on Tuesday to being
involved solved in the cover-up of
guillen's death Aguilar pleaded guilty
to one count of accessory after the fact
and three counts of making a false
statement Aguilar was the girlfriend of
Aaron Robinson an army specialist who
shot himself when police confronted him
investigators believe Robinson killed
Vanessa again in 2020 cut up her body
burned it and then buried the pieces in
three shallow Graves
a lawsuit filed against former Center
and live actor Horatio Sands has been
dropped court records from New York show
both parties appear appeared or agreed
to drop the case in the 2021 suit a
woman claimed that Sans groomed her when
she was 14 and then sexually assaulted
her when she was 17. Horatio Sands had
previously denied the allegations he was
a cast member for SNL from 1998 to 2006
and was the Show's first Latino cast
member